[Musique]
marcel jouhandeau 75 ans sans doute l'un
des plus grands écrivains français
vivant et comme beaucoup d'entre nous
parisien il aime feuilleter son album de
famille c'est que comme beaucoup d'entre
nous parisien il est venu voici plus
d'un demi siècle dans le petit village
de campagne dans l'image maintenant on
tremble toujours un peu dans sa mémoire
au point de lui sembler parfois presque
irréelle et que de la retrouver ainsi
dans cet album le photos jaunies par le
temps
le rassure comme si tous ces visages
oubliés qu'ils y rencontrent lui
témoigner qu'il ne rêve pas que cette
terre l'attendra jusqu'à son dernier
voyage
la france foisonne de millions de ses
cousins qu'on n'avons jamais vu et qui
sont pourtant comme nos doublures
ils nous gardent la place en quelque
sorte si nous les voyons sur yon
seulement capable de les reconnaître
est ce que vous connaissez votre cousin
blanche et de saint sulpice le guérétois
monsieur jouait bien mais il doit y en
avoir plusieurs rangées blanche et il ya
encore une horrible ou bien encore lorie
blanche et vous ne le connaissez pas
c'était en danger je le connais je sais
ça faut que je vous la montre et je sais
que vous aimez les visages c'est un
homme déjà d'un certain âge me ressemble
bien à un besoin de vous faire un dessin
sur ce visage ya une espèce de mort que
je trouve certainement un homme qui aime
la vie et qui aime le bon vin
mais celui-ci même club où il a l'air
d'un des personnages aimés cézanne
voudrait pas peut-être oui les joueurs
de cartes ou des jo qui un jour qui sait
de la mort
quoi d'étonnant d'ailleurs si ses
cousins nous étonne il nous étonne comme
vous étonnerez notre enfance ivoula
rencontrions notre enfance qui aurait
grandi tout seul loin de nous et dont
nous aurions un peu peur et je les
cousins que ce un style de nous qui
sommes parti qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
cousin blanche et du cousin jouhandeau
quitte à paris
dans sa charrette opale son cheval en
écoutant parler j'ai fait le voyage qui
mène de l'un à l'autre de l'absent à
l'autre absent de celui qui reviendra à
celui qui n'est pas parti j'ai servi
d'intermédiaire vous connaissez votre
cousin joindre aux le pari ne connais
pas enfin donc j'ai connu son père
n'était douce mais jamais vu une photo
la joue la montée oui à décembre son
père ah oui oui c'est dans le grand john
salmons oui c'est bien ça figure
comment sont faits avec un look de
figure ils savent bien que rouge était
bouché dans l'une dans la rue de la
mairie un débit je connais pas et je
joue là parce qu'il peut retrouver à
paris nantes l1 et les écrivains à lévis
batterie et le sait s'il fait des livres
s'étaient déliées bout de la creuse
il serait bien une bascule est bon en
vrai que sur l'accueil fait aux intérêts
effet après les autres dans cette rue
ils ont bien dû pourtant se rencontrer
enfants je songe et au sort qui les a
séparés à l'instant qui a fait de l'unss
qu'il est devenu de l'autre ce qu'il est
resté
vous n'avez pas envie de faire autre
chose aussi j'avais envie d'être
fonctionnaires comme les frères un
analyseur gendarmes on m'a dit non
bruyant dames 1 oui mais c'était passé
gang a dit à 36 magasins du mètre 1 cm x
de gendarmes présents dans les free
agents
j'opte elle bien pu passer quand même là
comme le mr x pas de spectre et et
qu'est-ce qui vous aurait pu être
gendarme ans et tu joues l'argent cette
confusion si la quête à l'arf est très
grave c'est hélas toujours et vos frères
qu'est ce qu'ils font et sitôt ce faire
il est mouillé il y en a un qui gueule
et les saisit pas bien du tout les
retraites et sait pas où et pas moi ou
achètent toujours à ces housses qu'il
voulait être lorsqu'il était jeune votre
cousin henri blanche smith ne sais pas
où est cette gendarmes c'était son rêve
un bon club je crois pas à cause des
lignes femme lacoste la retraite je
crois que c'est plus arrive c'est un
rêve quand la quelquefois on est ici
faisant ça c'est des choses qui sont
totalement étrangères moi je n'ai jamais
pensé à la retraite les gens j'aime pas
bien la ville j'aime pas ce gouvernement
où il ya beaucoup tu es tout roule
moitié dedans et puis je vous dis j'aime
bien ma liberté
sigen d'asseoir lu ma chambre et si je
travaillais travail tu peux pas
travailler c'est pareil cas alors si je
m'en excuse à l usine comme j'en
rencontre où il faut il faut il faut
partir des foyers à l'air tandis que moi
que j'arrive 1h09 en or c'est pareil
cela il faut faire ça va quand même mais
j'aime travailler les points forts et
puis avoir la liberté comme ça les
pendules idée de comment lui dire aux
cousins blanche et que le cousin
jouhandeau ou d'autres à paris peuvent
quand même respirer un autre air que le
sien
mieux une ville ouais vous empoisonner
dans ces villes a compris ou celui des
buteurs
mais même moi quand je m'en mets même la
guerre n'était pas loin à guéret guéri
c'est une petite ville l'airé bon augure
et non la réponse si vous voulez mais il
ya dix usines quand même en respirerait
acama vicié contre les hausses étaient
plus le même chemin que chez nous c'est
pas pareil et le cousin juin doit paris
que peut-il connaître réellement ces
gestes quotidiens du cousin blanche et
peuvent ils avoir d'autres consistance
pour lui que celle des choses que l'on
croit vivre en rêve
même le temps qu'on me v'là paris à
saint sulpice n'est pas le même temps
des loisirs
vous savez on n'est pas loin de guéret
mais on va à la foire comme on dit à la
fois il ya plus de foire le présent
c'est fini ça les bêtes qui est une fête
à laquelle serait fait ailleurs on va se
promener avec les autres on voit ça on
faisait chacun des entrées quand on
parle de culture
elle aurait pas il n'y a pas déjà debout
comme ça c'est le dimanche
aujourd'hui aux kiwis au cul oui mais
jamais au cinéma vous aux poissons et
aux non ça ne dit pas grand chose
pourquoi ça vous serez pas au ça me
plaît pas des fois ça dépendait du film
ça allait penser c'est qui ça parle peu
de culture j'aime bien avant en vérité
le vieux blanche et pense qu'il n'aura
pas à donner ses terres puisque son fils
adam sera là pour les travailler du
moins pour l'instant
le pouzin armand est il là il est là
mais il est aussi ailleurs ils rêvent
ils rêvent 1h chose un tas de choses
auxquelles le pouzin jouhandeau lui ne
rêvera jamais derrière ces chevaux dans
la brume matinale
il rêve aux vieux qui ne veut pas
acheter de tracteurs et le vieux aussi
rêvent ils rêvent aux jeunes qui rêvent
au temps où il sera plus là autant ou
sans s'être jamais vu ils se
retrouveront avec cousin jouhandeau dans
la même terre qui les aura ses paris et
réunit non parce qu'elle comprenait 12
en espace et grimper les tracteurs truc
cher il faut à milan il ya beaucoup de
voisins qui ont ma d'acheter un secteur
thur emprunter un million c'est bien
joli et sans traiter les eaux usées et
le million et profils i télé alors ça va
ça va pas avec un tracteur vous pourriez
labourer et plus vite et davantage ce
terrain oui mais votre souris mais c'est
un billion ça m
et mes deux chevaux et ne va pas
s'arrêter là elle ne sent très près tous
les gens commencent à voir pour un prêt
de six mois révolus 80000 à 80 milles
environ soit ça n'est pas que moi qui
l'ait d'enfants je verrai bien ce mois
un magasin devient acteur se sent que ça
ne fait pas de panique ont eu un sax
alto et droiture et tout mais j'aime
bien et joue aussi
j'aurais seulement dix à quinze mois
elle s'excuse pas à gérer si tu veux je
reste à la terre pour m'acheter un
facteur mais je comprends très bien la
situation
c'était bien de quoi je suis tout seul
c'est ce que je ferai d'abord il
faudrait absolument que les violences la
propriété à 55 au combat fonctionnaires
oui pour laisser aux jeunes que les
seuil jamais parce que vous disiez je
connais tu es né à côté là il ya un gars
il a 50 euros était toujours il est une
juge des tutelles de son père catégorie
c'est pas normal qu'on comprenne j'ai
pas fais pas ça non plus ça dépend
lesquels ont laissé pendant la campagne
et les bandes et moins par exemple à la
campagne allait moins bien habillée
la question est habillé marque en chine
tous les jours moi j'allais passer mon
fils et ma gorge et oui c'est bon je
vais bien dire habiller la petite bête
ben oui les femmes nana lo de leur
dimanche aller au cinéma à la télé
d après midi quand j'ai payé allait
passer quinze jours se barre la mère les
trois la voiture alors le matériel de
camping et tout le bazar sa campagne one
pourra faire ça je me disais il doit il
doit pouvoir trouver
d'ailleurs il est libre de venir quand
il veut attirer ces il habite saint
sulpice 60 le monde
et bien c'est un combien de km 5 km
gréau +11 4 kilos mais je crois alors
ils peuvent venir quand il veut adhérer
au cinéma ou
au café au théâtre quand il ya une sorte
de passage c'est aussi une question 12
mai pour lui un oui alors ça c'est
différent c'est un jour même aux jeunes
c'est déjà si elle n'est ce pas
l'agriculture peut-être qu'est ce qu'il
sait c'est armand parce que moi je
savais je ne le connais pas il a une
petite prime il a ni ferme à dire oui
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'agriculture
nouri à peine sonore qu'est-ce qui
lançait le cousin jouandou pour que la
terre continue à nourrir le coût des
armes à une deuxième vie chaque samedi
chaque dimanche il s'habille en monsieur
devant sa glace
il prend son vieux saxo dont il a appris
à jouer pendant la guerre il va faire
danser les gars et les filles dans les
bals de village penser que vous êtes
deux branches issues du même tronc et de
penser à tout ce qui vous sépare et tout
ce qui vous unit je crois qu'il ya quand
même
vous savez un un accord qui met kiev
elle savait mais un accord fondamental
alors le reste sont des variantes
l'harmonium le saxophone au fond est ce
bien vrai sac le saxophone du cousin
armand c'est la même chose que
l'harmonium lui cousin jouhandeau est ce
bien vrai que le cordon ombilical n'est
pas coupé ces gens si différents
ils me font penser plutôt à des
voyageurs qui marche seul
et pourtant tout près l'un de l'autre
dans une forêt au bout il ya le passé d
un l'avenir des autres cette terre où le
cousin jouhandeau espère qu'un jour il
retournera et où le cousin armand espère
que la musique lui permettra de rester
comme son père cette ferme tout de même
c'est à vous alors si oui chez moi après
il est il la garde papy va travailler à
l'usiné
ça vous ferait pas plaisir et non sous
traitantes et orléans voudriez j'aime le
bien qui travaillent la terre avec moi
même
qu'est-ce que ça m'a donné à cette peine
pour pallier cette terre m'a donné
beaucoup de peine
[Musique]